[Music]
the bodies of four young women were
found wrapped in burlap on gilgo beach
we could have a serial killer you not
only have a serial killer you have a
serial killer who's maintaining a
disposal site searchers looking for more
victims of a suspected serial killer who
found another body discovery of a fifth
set of human remains serial killers do
not stop killing these guys kill
recreationally a disturbing new
discovery was bringing the total to
eight a killers personal graveyard we
got another body and in another one the
ninth
and possibly tenth victim there's no
time
13 o clock
[Music]
all right we're here again and it's
episode 91 as 91 yeah there's only nine
websites to learn hundredth episode of
Glee crap I really knew start working on
this yeah
today we're gonna do the show drinking
coffee before we've done it where we
were what drinking mojitos it's a little
early you hear a slurping on coffee
they're just wizardry yeah that's right
and bust out to Java you guys we're on a
coffee break with 13 o'clock now this
show is gonna this is kind of like a
serial killer
extravaganza man because this was
actually a listener request this case
and the more I looked at like I had
heard about it I think I summarized it a
little bit in one of our 13 o'clock in
minutes videos but the more I looked
into this case cuz initially I was gonna
put this case in another case on one
episode but the more I looked into this
I'm like yeah this needs a whole show
finish the Long Island serial killer
okay
also known as the Gilgo Beach killer
this is British or the Craigslist Ripper
no law its American okay New York all
right and it's it's fairly recent it
only goes back to the mid nineties that
they know of and I'm gonna apologize at
the outset there's a lot a lot of
information out there about this case
and you know there's tons of
documentaries there's tons of other
podcasts most of them try to do it in
several parts just because the case is
so complex and it has all these like
tendrils and goes off in all these crazy
directions and it's not even really
entirely certain if we're talking about
one killer and there's the whole thing
about the you know the victim that was
found that led to the discovery of this
killer yeah
maybe not even being a victim of that
killer it's like there's just all kind
of crazy I don't know if there's a
serial killer or if this oh there is
they just don't know how many of us are
there might be two or three
might be more than one okay so they're
not really sure so I'm gonna get all the
I know this game no you know but it's
like it's really interesting and the
more I got into it its ongoing or what
years are we talking about basically
most of the women that disappeared
disappeared from about 2003 to about
2010 okay so it's further back yeah the
bodies were found 2010-2011 okay so yeah
they and they think the guy is still out
there this is in your new book no but
maybe one in one of the future ones when
you get it would have to be a future on
yeah because you know the date isn't
right yeah the faceless villain is so
far as that rest trilogy is only could
be 20th century so nothing mm nothing
past 1999 right all right and you know
the more so I the more I looked into
that so I'm gonna apologize but if I
don't get as much into as much detail
you know is maybe some other things do
cuz like I said this needs like a
several part thing probably but I'm
gonna try and Geneva basically and over
short summary of it yeah and then I was
like well since we're doing another
serial killer another true crime then I
guess on the news segment we can do some
kind of serial killer news I figured we
would probably do a golden state killer
update now we're recording this on
Sunday the Sunday before it goes up
right now GSK is Joseph D'Angelo he is
supposed to be appearing again in court
tomorrow but I don't know if there's
gonna be like any more revelatory sniper
[ __ ] right the most significant thing
that has happened in the last few days
concerning his case is that Joseph
D'Angelo has now officially been charged
with all 12 of the original Night
Stalker murders that makes me think he's
confessed maybe you know cuz previously
I think that when we did the show we did
the update show I think he'd only been
charged with six crimes maybe eight but
now he's been charged with the final
four and these are the canonical
original Night Stalker murders charged
with all 12 of them I got a feeling he's
negotiating with the DA dude for a life
sentence in exchange for a row yeah
because they don't base achill II what
BTK got I mean the death penalty
is still on the table according to the
press what they're trying to do now is
that they had a meeting on Friday which
was May 11th because the crimes took
place in several different jurisdictions
of earlier counties they're trying what
they're what they want to do is they
want to try him in one place where all
of the borough's but they don't know
what the logistics of that are gonna be
they don't know where the venue is rebbe
so they're trying to meet and they're
trying to like hammer all of that
telling you right now this death penalty
thing is a pipe dream because even if he
gets convicted of it and they given the
death sentence it takes 15 20 years did
you get all the yeah yeah 70 something
years old he they're not gonna put that
guy to death but they probably they're
gonna make it easy on them they're gonna
say plead guilty to all this stuff and
you can come forth just like the BTK did
you know what I mean in Grand Stand and
tell everybody your story tell us where
all the bodies are buried and then we're
gonna you send you to a nice comfortable
Penitentiary where you gonna live out
your final years the families through
that [ __ ] again yeah and like I said I
really hope that they can come to some
agreement on where they're going to hold
the trial because they're like if they
can't come to an agreement they're gonna
have to drag his ass all up and down
California you know and try them in
different counties for the dip for the
different crimes and they'll just spend
all that money yeah and it just seems
like a waste of money it's like they're
trying to get it all one go all 12
crimes they're gonna they're gonna offer
him a sweet deal I mean biologically she
got away with it
Yeah right I mean this today he there's
not enough years left in his lifespan to
sufficiently punish him he should have
been caught back in the 70s yeah I
should have rotted for decades in there
nice how that happened he basically got
away with it I mean I'm glad they got
him but you know
you got away with it the only other news
that's come up on him lately and I'm not
super sure how accurate this is because
I've really only seen it reported by
like radar online or like the Daily Mail
and stuff like that you know not the
most reputable publications so evidently
a family member of Joseph D'Angelo said
that what could have spurned his life of
crime or whatever was that when he was 9
or 10 years old he saw his younger
sister get raped on an army base or a
Navy base in Germany like by servicemen
I don't like I said I don't know how
true that is
it's I've only seen it like appearing on
a couple of different websites yeah so
you know and and I don't know if they're
just putting that information out there
now because they think because the
defense is putting that out there like
that's some kind of mitigating
circumstance like he was so upset by
seeing his little sister get raped he's
gotta go around rebut yeah that it
messed him up and things like that so
like I said I don't know if that
actually happened but yeah so if that's
something that has also come out to tell
you one thing the goldens say killing
one of our subscribers and named Petra
she's a girl from LA Czechoslovakia she
sent me a private message she said boy
you know you got a lot of hits on
original Nightstalker video and she says
what why do Americans care about that so
much you know those killers why is it so
popular just because it's not popular in
Eastern Europe writi much yeah I said
well because they're monsters they're
monsters that really existed a lot of
the monsters we grew up with we're kind
of based on serial killers you know a
werewolf is basically a medieval
interpretation of a serial killer yeah
yeah he looks normal then he turns into
a beast and he kills people one of the
first serial killers captured claimed he
claimed himself to be a werewolf a
French guy back in the middle Middle
Ages yeah yeah yeah and then you know
you find a dead woman and she's torn up
you know with teeth and you're like oh
man that's that's a werewolf an animal
did that but look it was kind of like a
man look if the evidence is left behind
there's a wolf and a man yeah the wolf
man and then he said well you know maybe
it was like a Dracula maybe that was you
know human couldn't do that
maybe that was a vampire yeah and that's
where that [ __ ] comes from I'm really I
I'm really interested though in the
cultural differences between because
yeah like Americans and Europeans to to
to about the similar extent are you know
true-crime crazy
we love serial killers we love you know
we don't love sir okay let's obviously
but we like reading so a real killers
well it's the formal fascinated by their
psychology and they're like that and
yeah so but I didn't even like think
that maybe other cultures might not be
yes but you know you know America you
know it's a big market for horror yeah
and horror fiction and I put you know
serial killers with horror nonfiction
you know it's it's a nonfiction version
of horror yeah it's a real monster you
know and that's it sells yeah you like
it it's interesting too because I like
to be scared so you know people who
don't like fictional or what true crime
yeah met a lot of people like that
well yeah you know it's a way of being
scared people like to be scared yeah
you're being scared of something
actually exists okay some of these cases
you tell me about you know an hour I
hear about these cases they do kind of
make you look over your shoulder like
man this those [ __ ] are out there you
can be laying in bed one day wake up
with a flashlight in your face and you
got this D'Angelo maniacs and get out of
bed you know the Wraith under life and
stacking dishes on top of you yeah
that's exactly what I did yeah like a
damn commando
yeah like commando yeah yeah pretty tape
on that [ __ ] yeah and the another thing
too and this was actually another piece
of serial killer news and this was sent
to me by one of our Australian superfans
Gareth yeah he sent me this on my yeah
oh yeah I don't supposed to think to an
American an Irishman yeah he sent this
to me in my facebook messages apparently
Dennis Nilsen the infamous British
serial killer kind of like the British
Jeffrey Dahmer yeah I know that guy we
remember we did a show about blighter
suckling old dirty prize yeah yes the
one where they caught him because all
there were like chunks of you in
in his drains mr. meat pipes and then
they found like he would keep the bodies
again Oh Rob and then the closet
yeah yeah nasty well I've done in bags
Dennis Nilsen
has passed away okay 72 years old he was
still in prison
obviously they never let him out they
were actually when when he was first
convicted in 1983 the recommendation cuz
like I said the laws over there not
quite the same and I don't want to say
anything too definitive you know because
I'm sure some of our UK listeners will
correct me if I'm wrong but in
particular cases like these for new
serial killer cases are particularly
egregious crimes I think they do have
the option of not of not giving them
like a solid sentence like you know ten
years and you get out or 25 years right
now they can say definitely oh yeah they
can say indefinitely or they can say at
least 25 years and then we'll reassess
right like we'll see if we should let
him out because a lot of the worst
serial killers over there um they
usually get like what I think it's
called a whole life Sarah or something
like that the or it will come a time
where it seems like the end of their
sentence and then the judge is like that
because it's like they have not shown
any improvement they have not shown that
they're sorry they you know so they just
leave them in there yeah kind of like
they did a little of Manson Yeah right
similar kind of thing same as important
you know tempted with a parole but yeah
he never made it yeah and same deal with
this Dennis Nilsen was he's been in
prison since 1983 and they never let him
out so he he is dead now they are
investigating his death but the article
says well they do that for anybody that
dies in custody so don't live jump to
conclusions like someone beat him to
death or anything like that he might
have just died of natural causes he was
72 years old so there was another
scumbag
taking of Manson though you know he
never really actually killed anybody
himself he didn't know Mick see wonder
you know they probably shouldn't have
let him out eventually
yeah there's a cult leader he told him
to do that but they were crazy enough to
do it he definitely should have gone to
prison but I don't know if he should
have gotten like well I guess you know
what you know what he should have
because that would be conspiracy to
commit murder yeah basically
he was trying to start a race war so
yeah keep that [ __ ] locked up
yeah you just talked yourself had to
stop myself he blocked up oh there was
another thing I forgot to mention in
regards to the Golden State killer Paul
holes who was one of the detectives who
was working on the case where he's like
a retired detective that that had helped
out in the case previously he actually
came out of the media saying that he
thought it was possible that the Golden
State killer had had an accomplice
at least on his early crime not in the
murders right but early on and there in
the rapes and the burglaries and he's
kind of pointing out that in some of the
cases the victim is that survived you
know said that they heard him talking to
someone else or that they heard someone
else's voice like a woman's voice or
something like that now that only
happened in maybe four the cases where
one of the victims actually said that
that they heard him talking to someone
else so the main investigator on the
Golden State killer case now is saying
no that's absolutely not true we're not
you know this is the guy he's the one we
don't think he has accomplished however
Paul holes is saying he thinks it's
possible that he could have had an
accomplice and more needs to be looked
into that so possible but I would think
I'm likely I would think that was
unlikely as necessary complication yeah
him to bring somebody along yeah and he
doesn't seem like the type of person who
have what would kind of he'd be
violating OPSEC which is operational
security right now you have a witness
that you don't have total control over
like let's say it's a girlfriend yeah
it's a wild card yeah you have a
girlfriend and that [ __ ] works out for a
few years and then you break up yeah and
then she's out there and she decides
that she doesn't like you cuz you fool
around on her or something and she goes
to the cops yeah that's the end she's
not on their ass that's right so we
burglarized the house yeah he tricked me
into it you know she rolls over you've
stayed evidence for a life sentence or
no sentence you know yeah like he does
seem like too much of a control freak to
that he wouldn't do I mean unless they
were like his super super early crimes
and he wasn't really sure he wasn't
doing much what wasn't doing much at the
scene of the crime right he doesn't do a
good type of person that that won't do
that once he got on a roast reasons once
he got on a roll here too
operational security he says all
commando you know and like I said on one
more before we get into the Long Island
serial killer thing I found this really
interesting article about the preferred
jobs of serial killers and how the
serial killers that they have captured
yeah they've actually distilled down
what their most common jobs are that
they these jobs they have more serial
killers and they're like over like you
know represent over right what do you
got so the interesting thing the top
three skilled serial killer occupations
this is weird because they're very
specific number one aircraft machinist
or assembler weird yeah number two
shoemaker or shoe repair person uh-huh
yeah I thought that was very strange
yeah three automobile upholsterer yeah
okay top three semi skilled serial
killer occupations number one forestry
worker or arborists weird number two
truck driver which that doesn't yes Rhys
name is brother three warehouse manager
also not all that's a present this is
just some statistical [ __ ] it's guys
are just like really interesting though
I thought the skilled ones were the most
interesting right like I say because
they were so specific the top three
unskilled serial killer occupations
general labor like a mover or Lance near
a hotel corner or a gas station
attendant right top three professional
or government serial killer occupations
one police officer obviously or security
guard two military personnel or three
religious official yeah interestingly
since we're talking about the Golden
State killer who was a cop and was also
in the military Dennis Nilsen what had
also been a cop and had also been in the
military so there you go there's two of
them right there but so the article was
kind of saying that maybe the reason
that because these are all types of jobs
that are not as common anymore because a
lot of them are like you know skilled
labor and things of that nature and
they're kind of saying maybe that's why
you don't see as many of these serial
killers nowadays or they're targeting
victims in a different way they said
back in the day they you know a lot of
these killers would use their jobs you
know like a truck driver or something
like that to target their victims
they're like a nowadays not so much of
that anymore they said now it seems like
killers are targeting their victims
through online just like our guy today
so that'll be a that'll be a good segue
to segue into that or by like you know
online meetup groups that type of stuff
like more less employment-based and more
like interest based things like that so
I just thought that was kind of an
interesting article that I just saw pop
up in my newsfeed so since we're talking
about killers targeting their victims
through the internet this is really the
case with this particular killer that
we're talking about today if indeed it
is all one person or it is more than one
person they are calling him the Long
Island serial killer or the Gilgo Beach
killer or the Craigslist Ripper I think
I know who this is now now I think I
remember this case this is the one with
the Craigslist call girls meeting up
with somebody who and they never come
back yes and a lot of them yeah and
actually like above average looking
Craigslist type hooker girls they even
really look like hookers from what I
yeah no pictures of them yeah well yeah
they're escorts there are there
freelance escort yeah they look like
normal girls yeah
well most of them were they were just
doing that because knew that money yeah
I mean I think only one of them was a
drug addict that they know of the other
ones were just you know poor they they
were being evicted or something like
that they needed money quick and it kind
of sucks too because I think the fact
that that at least the four or five
victims that they identified were
escorts yeah I kind of feel like that
might have contributed to the cases not
being terribly investigated all that
well well you have to understand you
know how much more difficult it is to
tread it down who an escort has been
hanging out with yeah hang out with a
lot of people especially if dudes are
the ones that I'm remembering off the
top of my head they were quite good
looking I think weren't they yeah right
well you know they're probably getting a
lot of business you know from from what
I've got just how I remember to say
let's remember thinking at the time I
saw some news reports on it I was
thinking this is a
a man of means this is a guy that these
girls will go out with I'm kind of
leaning toward that myself yeah and you
know and I might get into that later on
boga so that's so it is the same case
that's craziest thing about this case is
that they probably they might not have
even found out about it if they weren't
looking for this one girl that might not
even have been killed by this person
right so this is how this goes
so it's May 2010 now this girl's Shannan
Gilbert she's 24 years old she's an
escort she has a craigslist site and
everything like that
now she is going out she lives in Jersey
City she gets a call from a client named
Joseph brewer
I don't Oak Beach on Long Island and the
area where all of all this is occurring
it's these kind of remote beaches up on
Long Island they're sort of there's not
a lot of houses on them but the houses
on them are pretty you know high-end not
like mansions or anything but it's you
know it's a pretty affluent area you
know it's like a big long highway called
Ocean Parkway there's beaches on either
side was like a lot of really bramble e
like rough terrain and then there's just
like little pockets of like you know ten
houses of let's take ten nice houses and
stuff like that so that's the kind of
area she's going up to she's been an
escort for a while so she's not a dummy
she works with a driver who goes with
her to all her jobs and waits outside
for her right so she goes to see this
client Joseph Breuer
and her cook her drivers in Michael pack
and he drives a black SUV he drives her
there and she goes into Joseph's house
this is only great about 2:00 a.m. right
now at about five-ish a.m. Shannon calls
9-1-1 and she says now and this is like
this is crazy because the cops will not
release the 911 call and they will not
release a transcript of it right now
right but you know I'll get into that a
little bit later now son yeah now some
people that say they've heard it says
that she sounds very frantic and
disoriented and that she
that there's like a struggle or
something like that and she's saying
they're trying to kill me or they're
plotting to kill me but then some other
people that have heard it said no
everyone was very calm now what I could
piece together
apparently she called 911 while she was
still in Joseph Brewers house they could
hear her voice
they could hear Joseph Brewers voice he
just said something like I'm going
upstairs or something like that they
could hear her drivers voice yeah
she keeps saying they're gonna kill me
they're gonna kill me that she runs out
of the house while she's still on the
phone with them so evidently the 911
operator is Raziel where are you where
are you but she doesn't really know
where she is because you know the driver
dropped her out there she's not familiar
with the area so she can't really tell
them where she's at right and apparently
they can't track it or they can't
triangulate it because I don't know why
but that but they couldn't figure out
where she was so evidently she runs down
the street she runs to this neighbor's
house this old guy I think his name's
Gus Coletti or something like that she
starts banging on his door help me help
me so he opens the door and he says okay
well come in here and sit down and I'll
call the police
and he says that she just says I like
looking at like no help me help me then
she runs off again sounds like drugs
well yeah just let me tell the story
though
okay so then he looks out and she's like
hiding under his boat and he sees the
black SUV with the guy in it he's like
what are you doing he's like I'm the
driver I'm looking for her and so they
were looking for and they can't find her
she takes off she knocks on this other
woman's door but the woman doesn't
answer the door but she calls the police
and Gus Coletti called the police too so
they the police did not respond to
Shannon's 9-1-1 call but they did
respond to the other two because they
knew where they were
so they said there's this girl out here
she's not her door she says she wants
she wants help but her notes the matter
there's this guy in a car that's
following her and you know whatever
finally the cops get out there this is
about five six o'clock in the morning
cops get out there it's kind of dawn at
this point they look all over the place
and they can't find her she's missing
the driver Michael Pak he said that he
drove around and looked for her for
about an hour but then couldn't find her
and went home now they interview the guy
Joseph brewer now the cop said he was
very
forthcoming said yeah I hired her for
Craigslist escorts she came to my house
he's like and then she started acting
real weird and paranoid and I went out
and got her driver and said hey get her
out of here because she was acting very
strangely I've actually seen girl kind
of do that years ago yes not using
around alcohol and clubs and yeah psych
psych medicine yeah the thing is I think
she did have bipolar dessert but I'm not
sure if she was on any medication I
don't know if someone dosed her I don't
know because according to Joseph Brewer
and like I said this guy he could be a
suspect so I don't know how much you can
trust what he's saying but the cop said
that he was very pretty open about it
they said they searched his house and
everything and they didn't find anything
suspicious but he just said she started
acting crazy like oh they're trying to
kill me they're trying to kill me and
then ran out into the night was banging
on people's doors and stuff and then she
disappears right now while they now her
her mom and sisters and stuff report her
missing
right now like this you know they
couldn't know the weird thing is that
even before they knew that she was
missing her mom Mary Gilbert gets a
phone call from this guy named dr.
Hackett and he lives right around that
neighborhood like only like five or six
houses down from Joseph Brewers house
the doctor says to Mary
Shannon's here I run a home for wayward
girls and I try to take care of girls I
try to get them off the street and off
drugs and stuff like that and she's here
and she's okay
and all this other stuff doesn't sound
that business and then later she got
another phone call from him and he says
oh she's run away and I don't know where
she went - all right so they go to this
guy and ask him about this and he says I
never called that woman hmm but then
when they check the phone records and
stuff like that later
he did call her he was trying to get out
of it yes the situation right so I don't
so he didn't but the weird thing is he
didn't have anything to do with anything
what's he even there no she was never
there she was never there she hadn't
even knocked on his door or anything so
the more they look into this guy he's
actually a retired police surgeon now
they said that he
kind of has the history of inserting
himself into like investigations and
stuff like for some reason and I saw
this really weird I mean he's a weird
day yeah I don't know if he had anything
to do with any of the deaths or anything
but he's for sure like a friggin okay
right he's like this big kind of chubby
fat guy he's a gray hair he's kind of an
older dude he was coming out from like
some deposition he had given about the
case and this crew was trying to give us
like you know why did you say that you
didn't call that woman and you did call
and all this other stuff he totally
faked a heart attack later Mike pretends
he's following us and then the crew is
like um do you need help no I'm fine I'm
a doctor I'm a doctor it was thing I
ever saw is attention or yes so this guy
is kind of like a wild card right yeah
okay so months and months go by they're
out looking for Shannan Gilbert now
sources differ some of the sources say
that there was a police officer and a
k-9 and they were just out on a routine
training exercise where some other
sources say no they were out actually
looking for Shannan Gilbert on this part
of Long Island now this guy and the dog
found a body like skeletal remains and
first they assumed well there's Shannan
Gilbert because it's right near where
she where she was last seen except they
pretty quickly came to the conclusion
that it wasn't her because she and
Gilbert had had she'd like been punched
in the face by like an ex-boyfriend at
some issue she had like a titanium thing
in her jaw right right and this skeleton
did not have that so they're like no
this is somebody else so then they start
looking they start expanding the search
and then they find another body and then
another one and then another one okay
four of them and they call these the Gil
go for now these four girls have all
been identified they found these these
were found in December 2010 all four
girls had been Craigslist escorts quizes
yeah
not really first of them was Maureen
Brainerd Barnes she was 25 years old she
was originally from Norwich Connecticut
she had last been seen on July 9th 2007
Melissa
barthélémy 24 she was from New York she
went missing on July 10th 2009 I'm gonna
come back to her in a minute because
some creepy [ __ ] happen with that stuff
Megan Waterman 22 she was originally
from South Portland Maine had been
missing since June 6th 2010 amberlynn
Costello 27
she was from North Babylon New York and
she had been missing since September 2nd
2010 like I said all four of these girls
been missing all this time all had been
craigslist escorts the creepiest thing
about the Melissa barthélemy case in
particular was that she she had been
living in the Bronx you know and it had
her adds up and stuff like that she met
with a client on the night she went
missing which was July 10th and then
after she disappeared her little sister
Amanda who I think was 15 at the time
she started getting calls from Melissa's
phone except it was a guy and a guy was
saying he was asking if she was a [ __ ]
like her sister you know and then later
as he called 8 times right each time he
would get them to get more sexually
explicit he said stuff like I told her
what he did to her sister I know where
you live I'm gonna do the same thing to
you that kind of stuff said the little
sister got the calls and the mom also
talked to him - they said he had a very
calm very soft-spoken kind of voice the
weirdest thing is that they put a tap on
the little sister's phone to see if they
could see where these calls were coming
from every single time that this person
called you know they try to triangulate
the location from self cell phone towers
yes every single time the person had
called it was from a super super busy
area of Manhattan inside the Port
Authority Bus Terminal right by Times
Square right by the Empire State
Building so there's no way you tree yeah
and he was always on for less than three
minutes so he knew right so that's why
they
kind of sort of thinking ah me the
killer is a cop like a lot of people do
think he is a cop or even though the
cops are like no it's not a cop it's
just that so many people watch you know
NCIS and stuff like that nowadays that
maybe everybody knows that because
everybody knows so much about police
investigation I don't know though I kind
of lean toward maybe this guy as a cop
so these four bodies were found and it
should be noted that the body of Shannan
Gilbert has not been found yet so these
are presumably they all looked as though
they had been strangled or suffocated or
something like that now some sources say
they were mutilated but I'm not sure
what the what the extent of the
mutilation was or died never saw
anything where that was described so
they're thinking that for sure these
were all killed by the same person right
who dumped them there right that's weird
yes so yeah one girl who goes up missing
yeah
Craigslist call girl but looking for
they discover a bunch is never a bunch
of other in that same area yeah yeah and
like I said just wait it gets weird
prime time to thing but yeah we should
probably take a break because we're 35
minute mark so we are going to take a
break right now and when we come back we
will talk more about the crazy case of
the Long Island serial killer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back talking about the
Long Island serial killer case yeah all
these weird Craigslist girls vanishing
and being found in weird places pretty
weird
yeah and what's weird about this you
know just for our forum listeners
prostitution is illegal in most of the
United States separate parts of Nevada
that's Nevada and then out there it's
confined to places like body rash and
stuff yeah they have places for that
yeah their brothels are highly
controlled so what they do is they try
to skirt these laws through call
themselves escorts where you paid to
hang out with this girl like a date but
the sex is free that's one way that they
can kind of get it yeah you can get
around it yeah they advertise off of
Craigslist they try to stop it recently
but there's no way you can control this
people gonna do whatever they want to do
he asked me I think to have a
constitutional right to do whatever the
hell they want but they're they try to
keep this [ __ ] down to a minimum
I definitely think they should legalize
it and you know yeah I think it would
make it much safer to go out safer I
mean obviously if it you know I think
the only downside of it you'd have to
make a bunch of rules because you don't
want corporations involved because the
way Americans do things you know we do
things like [ __ ] on roids we would
have chains of brothels like McDonald's
yeah you could drive through you have
drive-thru [ __ ] pictures of all yeah
maybe a lot of money there and all your
daughters would want to work there
that's not gonna be a corporate effort
that's that's that that's that that's
the danger of America that's America's
strength but if I had to be a prostitute
I would rather do it like that yeah have
to like go to Craigslist and go to some
Brando's house is never gonna murder
mind they would take over though think
about it you have Bill Gates buying huge
chains of them yeah you want to keep it
a small underground business I think
good control yeah all right so like I
said now the first four bodies they
found they're pretty sure this is the
same killer now these girls were all
identified and then you know winner came
and they couldn't really search because
you know the weather was bad and the
terrain up there is bad I see actually
seen pictures of video and stuff like
that they're like this is the kind of
place they're like no you think it's
Long Island New York and stuff like that
but one it's pretty remote - it's just
this Highway and they're like on either
side of the road they're like it's
pretty much just underbrush brambles
marshes they're like it's a it's a very
hostile terrain yeah they're like and
it's the kind of thing where you can
dump a body a hundred yards off the road
and no one will ever see it they don't
want to go in there yeah they're like
what you can't like it's just too thin
under brush is too thick and stuff like
that so he's like since there's nothing
like these bodies just laying around and
having nobody see them right you know I
mean it's not that kind of thing okay so
they found the first four bodies they're
still they still have not found Shannan
Gilbert I don't know what happened to
her well yeah so you know spring comes
March and early April while they're
still looking for Shannan they find four
more bodies yeah
also none of which are Shannon right
it's not funny it's like I know I laugh
but I'm just like just because it's
amazing so you know so they're so they
find four more victims then they're kind
of expanding the search into like the
the neighboring County and then they
find two more but there weren't it's
higher bodies they just sound like parts
of bodies right like they found a skull
and some teeth and stuff like that out
of the other so so now we're at ten
people not counting Shannan Gilbert
because their own found her yes so these
are these are 10 people out now they
identified the first four out of the
second set only one of them I think has
been identified her name is Jessica
Taylor she was 20 and she was from
Manhattan and she had been missing since
July 2000 and
three now the weird thing is that they
only found part of her her other parts
had been found in Manorville New York so
they used DNA to like match those two up
that it had been found at a different
time and she had been unidentified how
far apart is that um I think it's about
40 miles
okay so wasn't animals know she was cut
she was cut up cut up and dumped in a
couple different place yeah they said um
yeah on July 26 like shortly shortly
after she disappeared
they found her torso yeah it's 45 miles
east of gilgo beach in Manorville new
york so then later on you know during
this sweep in 2011 they found the rest
of her and then they matched it up yeah
they said plastic sheeting was found at
the torso a tattoo on her body had been
mutilated with a sharp instrument now
the rest of the bodies the rest the
remains were unidentified these included
Jane Doe number six this was a head a
right foot and hands that was found on
April 4th the rest of that body had been
found in November of 2000 in the same
part of Manorville New York where
Jessica Taylor had been found so that's
why for a while they thought maybe this
was two killers because not all of the
bodies were cut up the older ones were
cut up and were kind of spread out like
some of the pieces were a matter bill
and some of them weren't Gilgo so it
could be that this is two killers and
they just both happened upon this really
cool humping ground or it could be that
because the killer had first been
cutting up the bodies to kind of hide
where they were hide their identities
but then because he didn't get caught
you got ladies he got lazy and just said
[ __ ] it I'll just throw them register so
it's possible that it could all be one
person and they're mostly kind of
leaning toward I've seen some
investigators are like no we think it's
two killers right one but most of the
law enforcement seem to think they're
dealing with one one killer okay so Jane
Doe number six she has never been
identified there was also a John Doe he
was found April fourth a young Asian man
he was wearing women's clothing when he
was
so it's possible he was a prostitute as
well right there's been composite
sketches released of him and of the
other unidentified there was also a baby
Baby Doe
she was found about 250 feet away from
the partial remains of Jane Doe number
six this is a female toddler between 16
and 24 months and age no visible signs
of trauma
there was another unidentified body that
was called Jane Doe number three or I
think they also call her peaches they
think that that was the baby's mom right
she's out there working with the baby
because they had similar jewelry on and
stuff like that the one they call
peaches was actually a african-american
woman they call her peaches because she
had on her boobs she had a tattoo of
like a peach with a bite taken out of it
so that's what caused like I said they
didn't she was found out how long has
she been on that she had actually been
found because there had been flesh on
the body for them to see that right
well yeah but part of her was found in
1997 okay and then part of her was found
in 2001 that it was matched up later
like I said it was open out there for a
long time yeah yeah how the hell did
they get a good how'd they know what
contact is she had that was should've
all been decayed well like I said that
part of her was found in 97 97 okay so
what when it was fresh right right
there was also a Jane Doe number seven
this was found April 11th on
tobei Beach this was a skull and teeth
now these remains they later linked to a
pair of women's legs that had been found
in a garbage bag on Fire Island in 1996
so these older murders that like I said
the killer had been cutting the bodies
up and spreading the pieces Avrum eyes
which he didn't do later on
that reminds me that's from the same
time is that nanny that was killed in
Boston I was in Boston at that time
there must have been around 96 97 and
they just found her upper torso they
never found her lower torso yeah
remember that I once she was a British
nanny yeah yeah yeah
that was a famous case
famous case I remember they were just
searching the place upside down they
even questioned a friend of mine about
it who the guy who was in a band named
John's whiz he was in a band called
sleep chamber and they thought maybe you
know the cops are just you know running
blind they were asking anybody yeah now
but I had heard through the grapevine
that that they knew who it was that it
was her employer but there was no way to
pin it on him right likely suspect yeah
the the scuttlebutt was that she had
gotten pregnant by the employer the loss
she wouldn't have an abortion he didn't
want to lose his marriage the choked her
out yeah he had a special apartment
downtown where he was taking pictures of
her and stuff so he had a little love
nest with the nanny
so that pretty likely yeah that's
probably and then did the reason why she
was cut in half was to hide the DNA in
the possible unborn child you're out
right then I sounded like that yeah they
never find you know only find half
anywhere on the other half was during
that same time nice yeah yeah might have
been same or one more the one that kinda
had his ear about okay now we're going
back so these so these are ten victims
and this is not even including Shannan
Gilbert now they did eventually find
Shannan Gilbert's body about a year and
a half after she had gone missing now
the weird thing about how they found her
she was found not that far from where
she had last been seen she was found in
a marsh about a hundred about a hundred
yards off of the Ocean Parkway they
found the body but then a week later
they found some of her stuff about a
quarter mile away her purse her
cellphone her pants and her shoes the
craziest thing was that after they did
this investigation they said that her
death was accidental that she had
flipped out in this dude's house and had
run off into the marsh in the dark not
knowing where she was going and that she
had got caught apparently like people
that live there say these you know they
say marsh but they said slick quick
sandals you can't really run through it
it kind of sucks you down and there you
can get stuck in there so they're
thinking that she just ran off into the
dark
know where she was going and then ended
up falling into a puddle and drowning
okay or dying of exposure which I'm not
really sure I buy that I don't know the
whole thing about this is so weird
because now her family didn't buy it
either they said no we think she was
murdered what was that [ __ ] with the
9-1-1 call why would she have run off
into the marsh when her driver was right
there um you know why would she have
taken off her pants and shoes like in
the brambles and [ __ ] like that well she
was losing her mind though maybe but but
they only have other people's word to go
on that and like I said the cops won't
release the 9-1-1 call so we don't know
what she sounded like on the 9-1-1 call
and it could have been that someone was
trying to kill her and she was running
away from them so she just ran out into
a marsh and died of exposure possibly a
brown or drowned in quicksand except the
problem is that her body was found face
up which not usually consistent with
drowning Wow
now the family thought that she was
murdered and they thought that the cops
were being [ __ ] they got their own
coroner an independent coroner to do an
autopsy
now that coroner said the results are
inconclusive
however because her hyoid bone they they
couldn't find the two little horns of
the hyoid bone that's usually a sign of
strangulation so the independent corner
said I'm not saying she was murdered
right but he's like I'm saying it's a
possibility yeah now I have heard that
they did a toxicology report and that
there were there was no drugs or alcohol
in her system I'm not sure how accurate
that remind me again how long her body
been out there about a year and a half
yeah she was I mean there wasn't much of
her left it was pretty much just bones
and hair yeah but I don't know it seems
weird to me like why would she be
running through a marsh not knowing
where she was going I mean unless she
had a psychotic break or something like
that but even then it seems kind of
strange this what seemed strange
she was not strong enough to make it out
of that marsh yeah and like I said I've
heard some people saying some of the
cops say this and so I've seen some
residents say this is like oh it's like
quicksand it'll look like you know it'll
just suck you and you can't get out like
someone else has to pull you out
but then in another way I don't know if
the jeans that they found some people
said it was jeans some people said it
was jeans shorts but I was like
Woolworth a muddy they didn't really say
why'd she take her shoes off like did
the mud suck yeah it could I've been in
I've been in terrain yeah it could have
been in the army you have to pass that
kind of stuff maybe quite frustrating
especially if you're in the dark you
become very disoriented you're trying to
pull your feet out and it's going it's
sucking on Yin you lose the horizon you
get dizzy and you fall and it really
pisses you off to be caught neck yeah it
kids actually anyway when it's at night
and it's dark and you can't see still I
would think that she would have had the
strength to eventually make it out of
there unless maybe she just gave up the
ghost you know I mean maybe she just
she's losing her mind she was
disoriented she struggled a bunch of
hours maybe she just walked deeper out
into it didn't know where she was gave
up and died it could be good they said
I'm not taking a stand on that either
way because honestly I'm an experienced
wooden all right so I know that if if I
walk if I if I'm in the United States
and I walk in any direction long enough
I eventually hit a road but there are
people out there that don't think like
that you know oh my god I'm in the
wilderness there's no end of this I'm
gonna die you know maybe they panic if
you're ever lost just walk in a damn
direction if you're in the United States
you will hit a road within about 20 to
30 miles max you'd have to be up in the
Washington Forest to get lost for a long
period of time ya know so like I said
there's still a lot of controversy about
whether the police are saying they don't
consider Shannan Gilbert's a victim of
the Long Island serial killer like I
said they think those 10 yeah that they
found the bodies they think that's all
the same person they think that her
death was an accident like I said I'm on
the fence about that it seems very
coincidental that she ended up dying
right there where all these other bodies
were thought to and what was with the 9
call what you know that just seems like
too much of a coincidence and chances of
her being out there when that guy was
out there doing a dog that's very
slender yeah all right
you have to look at this from the point
of view of a rapist that Marsh would not
be a good place to rape somebody I think
she got lost it's possible yeah and the
elements overtook her but but the fact
that she was out there that night
actually led to them finding all these
other things which is why you're
commenting even if you know she wasn't
killed by that killer yeah then you know
that's why her story is so entwined with
theirs now the crazy thing is that now
her family is just showing that she was
also girls about the same age once there
were all in their 20s similar kind of
situation which like I said to me that
me deadly serial killer he's killed him
without even killing him yeah it's just
like so where's going yeah but now her
family like I said they were adamant
that she had been murdered they're
trying to sue the Sefo County Police
Department because you know they think
they're covering some [ __ ] up which
maybe they could because I'm gonna get
into that a little bit quickly here but
the craziest thing about this [ __ ]
crazy story like I said I know I'm not
gonna be able to get all in all these
tendrils Mary Gilbert Shannon's mother
yeah later on was murdered by her other
daughter yes it was weird because I was
watching there was a 48 hours
documentary about this that came out I
think there was one in 2011 and then
there was one in 2016 it was like an
update and it had an interview with them
on there they were still alive then yeah
but then later on evidently the daughter
flipped out [ __ ] schizophrenia I think
[ __ ] and hospitalized many times she
flipped out and stabbed him home to
death
damn yeah so that was a [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] crazy and she had like a couple
more sisters to them like a god those
[ __ ] right yeah there's two poor
remaining girls they must be like what
the [ __ ] man it's like the worst thing
ever okay so now that they've
established like I said that maybe these
ten are
the same person you know what suspects
do they have so those who think that
maybe this is two separate killers
they're saying well maybe the older four
victims which were actually they were
killed first but they were found second
that maybe that was Joel Rifkin who is a
pretty famous serial killer he's
actually he's in prison now he went to
prison in 1994 and he's still there he
was sentenced to 200 and three years for
the murders of nine women between 1989
and 1993 he's believed to have killed up
to 17 but he hasn't confessed him but he
has not confessed to these because they
did ask him about them because this was
a similar to his MO picking up
prostitutes and strangled him or whatnot
so they did ask him about the the for
older bodies and he said no that wasn't
me whether that's true or not I don't
know but they're saying it's a
possibility that the that the older ones
might have been Joel Rifkin now here are
some of the other persons of interest
now this guy James Burke he was the
former Suffolk County which is the
county where the bodies were found
police chief interestingly he was
actually rumored to have had many
relations with prostitutes one escort
came forward claiming that he had beat
her up yeah and tried to choke her Burke
also deliberately blocked this
investigation he did not want the FBI
involved the FBI were trying to get
involved and he kept not cooperating
they would they would have found his
connection to him right now this guy was
eventually he was eventually put in
prison because he got 46 months for
beating up a man who stole a duffel bag
out of his car that had pornography and
sex toys in it I don't know if it was
child porn
it just says pornography is life sighs
so yeah he beat up this guy and then he
got sent to prison so he is not the
police chief anymore
but but they did find evidence that he
had blocked the FBI from helping to
investigate this case so some people are
saying that's why a lot of people think
that maybe this serial killer is a cop
police chief maybe not maybe not
but maybe this guy knows who he is or
maybe we're working together maybe it's
some weird kind of sex ring or it could
have been that you know he he did
business with a lot of those victims
wait I thought that he thought that the
FBI would get into there with their
client list yeah and go wait a minute
hold on where you lose his job right so
he might not have anything to do with
the murder or say that he just didn't
want to be embarrassed by yes oh yeah
might have been that another suspect
like I said was Joseph brewer who was
the client that Shannon Gilbert had gone
to see and was one of the last people to
see her alive the cops don't really
think he had anything to do with it it
does seem dumb that they're like if this
is a serial killer he's obviously very
familiar with this area but that doesn't
mean you necessarily lives there maybe
he just summers there because
significantly most of the I think all of
the victims did disappear from the
summer months so maybe it was just
somebody that summer there or had grown
up there and had sense moved somewhere
else but they said it's someone that's
very familiar with the area but not a
lot of people live in this area so it
would be dumb to dump the bodies like
right by your damn house you know I mean
so another guy and I mentioned this guy
before was this dr. Peter Hackett guy
the guy that makes the fake to the heart
attack all that other kind of stuff
because they said that she and Gilbert's
body was found
well her stuff was found like not far
from his backyard you know there's a
little that actually on the 48 hours
documentary they show like a little
Google Earth thing of like where she was
you know where she ran to where she was
seen or where her body was found and
it's really not very far so it's not
very far from his thing now I don't know
I I don't know if I'd go so far as to
say he was a killer but he's for sure
sketchy and I don't know what his deal
is like why he kept calling the you know
Shannon's mom and all this other kind of
suits just seemed really weird I guess
they ruled him out later he lives in
Florida now so either so if he is a
killer trouble is another Florida net
yeah there was another guy that they
were looking at named James Bisset or
Bisset and this guy owned an aquarium
and he was a local businessman he lived
around there he actually committed
suicide two days after Shannon was found
also they
thought he was suspicious because he
owned a nursery and several of the
bodies have been found wrapped in burlap
sacks okay of a similar type like a
nursery type bag so they kind of thought
maybe it was this guy but he killed
himself so just a couple days after the
body was found so might have been him
don't know
however this guy here and this just
pretty recently came out it was only
September 2017 that this guy came to
popped up on the radar this guy's name
is John bit Rolfe now this guy is
actually a convicted murderer he's from
Long Island he was a carpenter and he
lived in that County and he was
convicted of the murders of two
prostitutes in 1993 and 1994 there was
also a third woman who was murdered
around that time and he's also a suspect
in that and he's a suspect in at least
one of the Long Island serial killer
murders now they know for sure that he
killed these two particular prostitutes
in the 90s because they found his semen
they matched it to his DNA you know they
said it's it's gotta be him it's like 1
in 8 quintillion or something like that
that it's not and the weird thing the
the 3 women that he killed back then
they called them the left shoe murders
these were prostitutes he picks them up
he killed them and then he left them in
the woods like with their legs open and
one of their shoes gone why I don't know
but so he didn't have to carry two but
yes
also he lived in Manorville which if
you'll remember that's about 45 miles
from gilgo beach however there was
another dump site in Manorville where
some of the pieces of the bodies that
were found a deal go Beach were also
found in Manorville and this guy lived
there so I'm kind of thinking some of
them may have been from is that this guy
may have that he may have done all of
them or he may
done the older ones right because like I
said for sure he did those two from 93
and 94 because they have his DNA so and
they also said his neighbor said stuff
about you know he was into killing small
animals and you know doing sin he was
kind of like a creep and everything like
that
interestingly too is that one of his
known victims who was named Rita
Tancredi
she was best friends with Melissa
Barthelemy who was one of the Gilgo
Beach girls so and also the Melissa
Barthelemy --zz mother said that Melissa
had gotten a lot of calls from
Manorville right so it could be that
this guy did all of them right all ten
of them but he is in prison now so for
those two murders so if it is him he's
in jail but if it's not him then the
dude's probably still running around
somewhere
so like I said there's like so much more
to this I didn't even get into it's a
huge huge case there's like so much [ __ ]
going on like I said it's the whole
thing with the crazy coincidence about
Shannan Gilbert was she murdered was she
not was an accident you know and and
just the fact of her going missing in
that particular way and that's how they
found the body so let me ask you this
have any new bodies been discovered
since not so far now so this may not be
an active case may been something that's
over with now right maybe the guy did
kill himself yeah and like I said some
from what I've seen it does seem like
most people if if they think they think
maybe it's a cop maybe there was some
kind of cover-up something like that it
does kind of seem like the investigation
was sort of botched I don't know if it's
necessarily because of a cover-up
cover-up or are being a cop or anything
like that or if it's just kind of like
oh they're just hookers who cares you
know it might be that kind of thing I
don't know I think I think well I think
that the one cop who was trying to stop
the investigation
I think it's cuz he was doing business
with those girls and even want to get
exposed right I have a feeling that the
killer himself though is probably more
like an upscale Gary Ridgway
he's kind of an insignificant type of
guy but he he's making more money than
Gary Ridgway and he has access to
Craigslist and he picks out good-looking
girls and strangles some of them
and as some people are saying that this
is probably a wealthy individual you
know upper middle class individual
because and they also are saying that he
maybe is super charming yeah or he's
maybe someone that kind of cultivates
relationships first because they must
trust him they said some of those girls
were convinced to leave their cell phone
yeah at home right when they would see
it because they said a lot of these
escorts usually what going to a client
they'll make the client come to them or
they'll have like a bodyguard with with
or something like that just like Shannon
did that say knew they know the guy so
they must know him that he must have
been cultivating an information
relationship about date one of them off
and on right and then he kills and also
it should be noted too that a couple of
them like one of the roommates of one of
the victims said that this guy kept
calling her and was offering her like
$1500 we're always like way more than
she normally charged so he was like very
insistent so this was obviously a dude
with money like I said it may be a dude
that summers right there you know not
necessarily someone who lives there
because it seems dumb the kind of [ __ ]
where you eat you know and just don't
bodies right there by your house but he
he for sure is familiar with the area
and I I'm kind of leaning toward him
being sort of a wealthy Gary Ridgway to
individual or something of that nature
alright so I guess we better wrap this
up cuz it's like I said it's like it's a
huge case and I tried to get to most of
the Sally details but I don't know if I
actually succeeded so you know it's kind
of rambling like it usually is no we
hope you enjoyed this serial killer
extravaganza for episode 91 and remember
if you like the show to like and share
and subscribe and tell all your friends
about us and also if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock or you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also
remember to check out our latest movie
review which was John Carpenter's in the
mouth of madness I just put that up a
couple days ago if you haven't seen it
also go to our Zazzle store zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock oh we have several
different t-shirts and a tote
that you may purchase and that'll do it
for episode 91 we will see you next time
bye
I am the serial killer I am the bloody
hand I am the chief [ __ ] take her I am
the chosen one
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you